سامي او ساري عرابي الكاتب والباحث
السياسي سيد ساري كل المدن المركزيه الان
تحت قبضه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الامنيه والعسكريه الموضوع تخطى مساله
اقتحامات
اعتياديه نريد توصيفا دقيقا لما يجري في
الضفه الغربيه خاصه هذه
الليله والحقيقه منذ السابع من تشرين
اكتوبر لا توجد اقتحامات عاديه في الضفه
الغربيه ولا سما في المرحله الاولى يعني
على الاقل اول شهر او 45 يوم كانت
الاقتحامات ايضا كثيفه وواسعه وتتسم
بعمليات اعتقال كبيره فضلا عن سياسات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في اغلاق الطرق وقطع
قدره الفلسطينيين على التواصل ما بين
القرى والمدن لكن بالفعل هذه الليله الامر
مختلف من حيث الكثافه والزخم يعني في لحظه
واحده في وقت واحد يجري اقتحام كل مدن
الضفه الغربيه بكثافه عاليه الى قلب مدن
الضفه الغربيه باللا استثناء لا يبدو ان
هدف هذه الاقتحامات هو الاعتقالات الواسعه
او شن حملات اعتقال كما كان الامر عليه من
بعد 27 اكتوبر واضح كما يتحدث الزملاء
المراسلون ان الهدف الاساسي من هذه
الاقتحامات هو مداهمه محلات الصرافه ربما
مصادره اموال ربما تحقيقات ميدانيه مع
اصحاب محلات الصرافه ربما اعتقال لبعض
اصحاب محلات الصرافه الحقيقه هذا السلوكي
يكشف طبيعه الاوضاع والظروف داخل الضفه
الغربيه على وجه التحديد وعلى وجه الخصوص
يعني بمعنى اطباق الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اقتصاديا وامنيا وعسكريا على ساحه الضفه
الغربيه وحاله الحصار التي يعانيها
الفلسطينيون على المستوى الاقتصادي في
الضفه الغربيه كلنا نعلم مصادره اموال
السلط نود ان نفهم اكثر لماذا محلات
الصرافه يتم استهدافها في هذا
التوقيت اعتقد ان في هناك سببين اساسيين
السبب الاول هو حاله التضييق العامه
اقتصاديا على الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه من اجل اشعار الفلسطينيين بثقل
حاله مقاومه وانهم قد يدفعون اثمان يعني
اقتصاديه قاسيه ه السياسه ممارسها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الانتفاضه الاولى
ومارسها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الانتفاضه
الثانيه واضح تماما ايضا سياسه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في ابتزاز السلطه الفلسطينيه
على المستوى الاقتصادي من خلال مصادره
اموال المقاصه كذلك العمال الفلسطينييون
الذين يعملون في الاراضي المحتله عام 1948
الان هم يعني يعانون من حاله من البطاله
في هذا الوقت بالذات وبالتالي لا توجد
اموال للعمال لا توجد اموال للموظفين ومن
ثم واضح تماما ان ثمت حصار اقتصاد يطال
مثل هذه المؤسسات او المصالح والمشاغل
الاقتصاديه مثل محلات الصراف هذا اولا
سياق عام اعتقد ان في هناك سياق خاص وهو
محاوله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تجفيف كل ما
قد يعتقد او يظن انها مصادر من مصادر
تمويل الفصائل الفلسطينيه داخل ساحه الضفه
الغربيه لكن اعتقد ان هذا السلوك من
الاحتلال مبالغ فيه الى حد كبير لا يعقل
ان تكون كل محلات الصرافه هذه من اقصى
جنوب الضفه الغربيه الى اقصى شمال الضفه
الغربيه كلها تكون بمثل هذا دور وبالتالي
انا اعتقد ان الشيء الاساسي هو نوع من
التضييق نوع من الترهيب نوع من التخويف
حتى لا تكون مثل هذه المصالح الاقتصاديه
لاحقا او في وقت تالي بتخفيف الضغط
الاقتصادي عن ساحه الضفه الغربيه او من
خلال يعني تحويل اي عمولات او اي اموال لا
تمر من تحت عين او يد الرقيب الاسرائيلي
او قد تستخدم في وقت لاحق في تمويل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه داخل الضفه الغربيه
انا اعتقد ان هو سلوك احترازي سلوك
ترهيبية الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من انتفاضه
ثالثه
ن الحقيقه الضفه الغربيه يعني هي تشهد
حالات متتابعه مما يمكن ان نسميه بالهبات
الكفاح والحالات النضالي المتتابعه ليس
فقط من بعد العام 2021 ذلك العام الذي
اتسم بتصاعد كبير في العمل المقاوم وكذلك
العام 2022 ولكن حتى من بعد العام 2014
نحن نتحدث عن هبات متتاليه موجات كل موجه
تسلم نفسها الى موجه اخرى يعني هبه العام
2014 و15 و17 و19 و2 منذ العام 2021 وحتى
هذه اللحظه الضفه الغربيه في الحقيقه لا
تهدا حتى من بعد احداث 7 اكتوبر اذا نظرنا
الى طبيعه الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه اعداد
الشهداء الفلسطينيين اعداد المعتقلين
الفلسطينيين في هذه الفتره الزمنيه
الوجيزه والمحدوده هي غير مسبوقه تاريخيا
لا في الانتفاضه الاولى ولا في الانتفاضه
الثانيه اذا نحن نتحدث عن حاله استثنائيه
تعيش الضفه الغربيه ولكن بطبيعه الحال هذه
الحاله قد لا تكون مرصوده بشكل جيد مقارنه
بال ال الجريمه المفتوحه داخل قطاع غزه
وعمليه الاباده الجماعيه الموجوده داخل
قطاع غزه وبالتالي هناك حاله كفاحه موجوده
في الضفه الغربيه تناسب طبيعه الظروف
الامنيه والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه في هذا
الظرف الراهن ليس بالضروره ان تشبه
الانتفاضه الثانيه او تشبه الانتفاضه
الاولى لكن بالتاكيد يعني اجابه مباشره
على سؤالك يخشى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان
تتوسع الامور بشكل اكبر مما هي عليه الان
ولذلك ربما يكون بمثل يعني هذه السياسات
الاحترازيه الترحيبيه والتخويف
للفلسطينيين عموما وكان سيد ساري ما جرى
في اي غزه في السابع من اكتوبر
ربما اعاد التفكير لدى الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في اعاده الترتيبات الميدانيه
وبالتالي ما الذي يحاول ترسيخه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
تحديدا اعتقد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قام
بمجموعه من الخطوات كي يشل قدره الضفه
الغربيه على القيام باي دور نضالي وكفاحي
اول هذه الخطوات اشرنا اليها وهي تقطيع
اوصال الضفه الغربيه المقطعه اصلا يعني
ربما
يعني ما لا يعلمه كثير من المشاهدين ان
الضفه الغربيه هي اصلا مقطعه بالحواجز
والبوابات الحديديه والابراج والطرق
الالتفاف والجدار والمكعبات الاسمنتيه هذه
بنيه استعماريه قائمه وموجوده دائما بعضها
فاعل وبعضها يجري تفعيله في لحظه واحده
منذ احداث سبعه تشرين قام الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بشل قدره الفلسطينيين على
الحركه ما بين مناطق الضط الغربيه كي يمنع
الفلسطينيين اولا كي يشعر الفلسطينيين
بحضوره الثق قيل الامني والعسكري وايضا كي
يمنع الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه من
المساهمه باي دور كفاح اي دور نضالي كذلك
سعى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى اعتقال كل
الكوادر والعناصر التي من شانها بحسب ما
يتصور او يتوقع من الناحيه الامنيه ان
تكون يعني مساهمه بتنظيم اي حاله نضاليه
داخل الضفه الغربيه ولذلك اعداد المعتقلين
ربما تجاوزت ال 4000 وربما اقترفت اقتربت
يعني من حاجز ال 5000 كذلك الخطوه الثالثه
التي يقوم بها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هي
عمليات الاقتحام اليوميه التي تهدف الى
اغتيال الفاعلين والناشط في مجال المقاومه
المسلحه على وجه التحديد والتركيز على تلك
البؤر الاكثر نشاطا على هذا الصعيد كيف
تفسر لنا سيد ساري غياب اي موقف من جانب
السلطه الفلسطينيه حيال ما يجري من
اقتحامات يوميه
ومواجهات انا اعتقد ان الاداره الحاليه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه لا ترغب بتكرار نموذج
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه في
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه لم تكن
انتفاضه فصائل لم تكن فقط انتفاضه شعبيه
ولكن شاركت في فيها قطاعات وشرائح يعني من
اجهزه السلطه الفلسطينيه منذ ذلك الوقت
انا اعتقد ان هناك العديد من المياه التي
جرت اسفل الجسر الفلسطيني من بعد انتهاء
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه وامتلاك
الاداره الحاليه للسلطه الفلسطينيه لتصور
مختلف يعني يرى خطا المواجهه المفتوحه مع
الاحتلال ال الاسرائيلي كذلك واضح تماما
ان هذه السياسه تكرست بشكل اكبر من بعد ما
يسمى بالانقسام الفلسطيني بعد العام 2007
فاظن انه بات صعبا على نخبه السلطه
الفلسطينيه وقياده السلطه الفلسطينيه ان
تغير هذه السياسه التي تكرست على مدار هذه
الفترات الطويله اذا كنا نسمع تصريحات
يعني اغلب قيادات السلطه الفلسطينيه في
مستويات متعدده هم يصرحون بذلك هم يعلنون
انهم ليسوا في وارد مواجهه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بعضهم قال ان السلطه لا تملك
قدره على مواجهه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بعضهم قال ان السلطه تريد ان تفوت هذه
الفرصه على الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكن هذا
الحقيقه يبقي السؤال قائما لان كل يعني
السياسات التي استخدمتها السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي ترغب من خلالها بتفويت
الفرصه على الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما تقول
لم تثمر في غل يد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفي
كبح هذه الهجمه الاسرائيليه على الضفه
الغربيه نحن نتحدث عن شهداء يوميا في ساحه
الضفه الغربيه نتحدث عن اعتقالات الى قلب
مناطق السلطه الفلسطينيه التي يفترض وفق
اتفاقيه اوسلو ان تكون المسؤوليه الامنيه
عنها فقط للسلطه الفلسطينيه والحقيقه هذا
ليس امرا جديدا منذ العام 2002 يعني منذ
عمليه السور الواقف العام 2002 وحتى هذه
اللحظه لا توجد منطقه واحده محرمه على
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من الناحيه
القانونيه يفترض ان تكون هذه الاقتحامات
مرفوضه وغير مقبوله لان اتفاقيه اوسلو
تقسم الضفه الغربيه الى ثلاثه مناطق مناطق
الف التي يفترض ان يكون الاشراف الامني
عليها محصور بالسلطه الفلسطينيه ولكن
بالرغم من ذلك قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تقتحم هذه المناطق وتمارس مثل هذه
الممارسات التي يفترض انها يعني ممارسات
محصوره في المسؤوليه الامنيه والاداريه
والمدنيه للسلطه الفلسطينيه ومن ثم يفترض
ان يكون السلطه الفلسطينيه موقف اقوى يعني
اذا لم يكن على يعني على سبيل مواجه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يفترض ان يكون هناك
موقف اكوى في اطر شعبيه اطر دبلوماسيه اطر
قانونيه اطر اعلاميه اطر دعائيه لكن من
الواضح تماما حتى هذه المستويات هي منخفضه
في مواجهه سياسه من هذا النوع